Lisa Marie Presley's first child
breaking her silence
so level-headed I love her and she's
much further advanced than I ever was
Riley Keough shares a touching photo to
Instagram letting the picks speak for
itself and only a heart emoji in the
caption the tribute comes a little more
than a week after her mother's death in
the comments Kim Kardashian Jenna Dewan
Olivia Munn and more a-listers offering
their support I'm just proud you know so
proud and she's so does her thing that I
respect how she wants to do it the
actresses Mad Max co-star Rosie
Huntington Whiteley writes been thinking
of you so much Lisa's final resting
place is Graceland and next to Riley's
late brother Benjamin who took his own
life in 2020. anything happening with
them I feel if they're sick I get sick
if there's something happens to them I'm
going through it it's really a beautiful
but painful situation Lisa Marie met
their father musician Danny Kehoe in
drug rehab they married in 1988 the
marriage ended after six years well
Danny it was just the stability I was
very much a homebody longest
relationship that I maintained the exes
were living together when Lisa Marie
went into cardiac arrest at home last
week a voice reported to be Danny is
hurt on the 9-1-1 call okay sir listen
permit's already on the way so that they
need to get in there I have no idea
where they're at right now so over I
think they're here okay are they there
with you
okay
all right thank you Lisa Marie will be
honored Sunday at Graceland with a
public celebration of life Riley along
with younger twin sisters Harper and
Finley will now inherit their
grandfather's iconic estate
is absolutely 100 mine always has been
mine Graceland always will be and when
it's no longer mine it will be my
children's